hey what's going on is bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
uh just checking in on you just checking
in to see how your workweek is going I
am here in Boston I'm gonna get ready to
do the [ __ ] cam neely Denis Leary
benefit on Saturday at the Boston Garden
DTD north bank garden whatever the [ __ ]
they call it how about your Boston
Bruins they're just on a tear even
though they lost a close one to the
hated halves that's good for the French
he's up there right they get to cry into
that little [ __ ] pocket squared
hankies I didn't love the way were
playing man playing incredible and I
have had barely had any time to watch
but I check out the highlights and I
can't hear myself for some reason I
don't know why do I need to push this
button here is that what it is all there
it is oh I need a new speaker why so
anyway I haven't you know I've moved
away from here so goddamn long ago
they're like I am having difficulty a
few times
understanding the Boston accent just
really upsetting to me because this is
where I'm from
I actually I did a couple of shows that
laughs Boston out on the pier it used to
be where Anthony's pf4 was way out there
you know drive out to this great Italian
restaurant it was like one of the
greatest Italian restaurants in the
country and but you kind of took your
life in your hands going out there
because it was kind of shady out there
out there in the wharf but now it's all
built up out there like everything's all
built up now so I went down there this
was a Thursday I went down there Tuesday
night to a quick 15 minutes set and the
club owner says to me he goes hey Bill
Julie over here and I was like what
jewel Bowie I had a like process
oh he's saying did you Boober over here
Julie over here yes I opened over here
do you over here hey Bill
hey barb you [ __ ] over here yes I did
I did over here so that kind of
surprised me
it's the first time in a long time I
think ever that I haven't been able to
understand I think it's because overs
has happened since I left so I haven't
heard Luba I always knew
jeet no Jew that was did you eat no did
you
I remember my vocab improvement teacher
in high school you said that's how you
started G no jus say now we need to
learn to pronounce our words more so I
knew that Jew was did you you know
most places it's the beginning of
something anti-semitic but here that is
did you Jew
Ubbe over here Jew boy over here
I learned a new one so anyway the first
night I went up and the crowd was like a
bunch of teachers I think because the
headliner was a teacher right and I
gotta tell you I did 15 minutes and when
I tell you that I ate my balls for 15
minutes I'm not I'm not joking it was
straight up just I mean I had lot you
know making fun of myself and all of
that [ __ ] throughout it but jesus
[ __ ] christ the way comedy has
changed I don't know I feel like I'm up
there playing like disco music in like
the 90s well in 90s it was actually kind
of cool and retro in the 80s like I
don't even know like people just [ __ ]
stare it at me you know I kind of went
up to a trash and white women in the
beginning so I didn't get him on my side
then I did the lesbian story
they kind of like that and then I did
the abortion thing and the Jesus Christ
just [ __ ] ate my balls but I was
having a good time there's just like
pockets of people laughing at me now I
feel and I just feed off of them and I
when I watch them laughing they're
trying to suppress it it doesn't make
any sense to me it's like you think it's
funny
could you help me out here and let it
out you know so but this is a very
caring time everybody cares you know
it's such [ __ ] did you see that
[ __ ] lady on ABC when she had the mic
because they kept saying and she was
talking about that [ __ ] Epstein guy
going we had this story three years ago
we had all evidence we had photos we had
film we had this lady we said we were
gonna protect her and all of that [ __ ]
an ABC douched that [ __ ] story
because they want they didn't want to
[ __ ] up their interview with Prince
Harry and his actress [ __ ] wife so
they walk away from a story about
underaged children being underage
children's redundant underage kids being
[ __ ] sexually assaulted raped and
everything on this [ __ ] island by all
these [ __ ] rich guys when they
cheated then she just then she [ __ ]
backs the hole in old time she was [ __ ]
and she goes how it drives me crazy I
thought that she was bitching more that
she didn't get the story she didn't get
the scoop as they say in that business
not that they were actually kids having
this horrible stuff done to them and
then she [ __ ] backs off the whole
thing go and that was a private moment
of frustration oh you mean the part
where you said you had evidence about
all of these [ __ ] super rich people
banging kids that was a private moment
of frustration and then it just all goes
away all these years you guys talking to
me about how I got a tinfoil hat on and
I talk conspiracy and all of this [ __ ]
you [ __ ] explain this one to me
where a news anchor says what the [ __ ]
she says
and that is it no investigation no
nothing do you think if she said that
about you or me or anybody else if she
[ __ ] said that [ __ ] in her private
moment of frustration the feds would be
descending on that [ __ ] News Agency
they get all the evidence they find out
who that witness was and then they go to
your house and you'd be cuffed as
opposed to her just going well I was
just a private little bit of frustration
can you [ __ ] believe I mean talk
about a [ __ ] sellout it's all about
money at the end of the day it's all
about money those guys who are doing
that [ __ ] horrific [ __ ] and they were
doing it I'm making so much [ __ ]
money that everybody looks the other way
and that woman there the news lady she's
you know she doesn't want to lose her
[ __ ] job so now she's just gonna like
be like yeah that was just and I was
just you know I was a little frustrated
that day so I was talking crazy
un-fuckin'-believable and that [ __ ]
thing and this is what kills me - is it
trended unlike Twitter for maybe a day
and now it's gone I don't [ __ ] get it
you know what I mean but if you're
trying to get on a sketch show that [ __ ]
lasts for a [ __ ] week and somebody's
pissed at you or you're a stand-up comic
or a [ __ ] actor you know let's it's
time to vet those people but super rich
people on [ __ ] rape island kid rape
island that's fine just yeah that'll
trend for like a day and then that'll be
it shouldn't somebody be investigating
that you had what story what evidence do
you have
who is this witness possibly we should
follow up who were the people at ABC
that squashed this story I don't know I
don't know I don't pretend to know I
don't [ __ ] understand it I don't
understand Wolvie Jubilee
so anyways I'm sorry so last night I
went back to laughs Boston I did
show did an hour of my [ __ ] in front
of my crowd then all of a sudden I was
funny again
I had a great time last night I wish I
recorded some of that [ __ ] cuz I said a
lot of [ __ ] and I don't remember what I
said but I remember it was really funny
so I've been having a good time the
whole [ __ ] Boston comedy scene I
don't even know where it is it still
exists I just don't know where it is so
I but that's been like the thing all
this week trying to find it and I felt
really fortunate that when I started out
there was two khat there was Nick's
comedy stop and there was the comedy
connection at Faneuil Hall and then dick
Doherty had all of these satellite rooms
and all of that [ __ ] and you know so
thank God laughs Boston it's laughs
Boston is doing the work of the old
connection and next comedy stop it's
crazy that's really weird
it's really where this was always an
amazing amazing place for stand-up and
the people here you know just going
around town talking to people there is
funny is ever and I don't know
so go out to laughs Boston support the
Boston stand-up scene [ __ ] great club
man it's a great club in what used to be
a bad location is now a nice location
the whole thing I used to I used to go
to Emerson College way back in the day
and Emerson has moved up the street into
where the combat zone used to be where
all the hookers and the drug dealers and
all of that [ __ ] and it's weird I don't
even recognize it anymore but it's a
good thing I don't know where all those
prostitutes went you know surprise the
news didn't interview them when they
talked about gentrification wait tonight
where will the [ __ ] go I haven't
sucking dick on this block for like I
don't know like 17 years and I feel like
I got at least another seven in me
I just just John's just all disappeared
people walking around carrying books so
anyway yeah that's been my deal and I
just been trying not to [ __ ] eat
poorly but let's talk a little bit of
sports here the your [ __ ] Boston
Bruins had a wild one against the the
Pittsburgh Penguins I got to watch a
little bit of the first and then some of
the second period and I missed the third
pair we scored like four goals it's
incredible the amount of goal scoring
and just how we haven't had this
hangover anything like that I'm just
hoping we got a couple of tough guys on
there cuz you know we owe the st. Louis
Blues a lot we owe them like we need to
run their goalie for seven [ __ ] games
and sucker punch people and then wink to
the guys on the bench oh I will never
[ __ ] get over that [ __ ] I will never
get over that that [ __ ] that's style
of play that I love that they just
[ __ ] they douched out of the whole
league and then all of a sudden is like
but this year we'll let the Blues play
it in the playoffs and they let one of
the shittiest [ __ ] teams in a long
time win a Stanley Cup you know be one
thing if everybody had a tough guy and
it was a [ __ ] level playing field
those [ __ ] [ __ ] penalized us out
of our own goddamn game for [ __ ] ten
years and then we show up with a knife
to a gunfight
yeah I never [ __ ] get over that [ __ ]
but congratulations to all the
long-suffering st. blues blues fans I'd
never take that away from get but Jesus
Christ they had one line in a [ __ ]
half-ass goalie unbelievable
anyway plowing ahead here I'm gonna be
doing some more stand-up probably
tomorrow night up on route 1 at giggles
my old pal ain't private E and I don't
know I'm really I don't know I'm having
a [ __ ] great time back here I do I
still have not gotten over to the
[ __ ] TD Banknorth Garden to before
all my nieces and nephews to buy all the
[ __ ] you know Bruins Celtics [ __ ]
then I got to go out too far
perón get the Patriots [ __ ] it's just
trying to get everybody to give you
their [ __ ] sizes has kind of been
taken forever so I got to admit though
you know after sitting there bitching
that there was no [ __ ] fish left they
were saying 90% of all species of fish
were gone and then I was just I was done
eating fish except unless it was
man-made salmon I'm not gonna lie to you
I did go to a Chinese restaurant and I
got some crab rangoon
I didn't order it my wife ordered it I
had a couple pieces of that and I was
just like now 91 percent of crab is gone
Chinese your question how the [ __ ] is
sushi still legal you know what I mean
everybody flips out you can't Club a
baby seal but all the [ __ ] fish are
gone and you can still go down and gets
just [ __ ] till your heart's content
each sushi still [ __ ] exists you know
there's not all you can eat Siberian
tiger right you can't eat polar bears
can you maybe if you're an indigenous
person because part of your culture they
allow you to do it you know shark fin
soup all of that [ __ ] everybody's saying
stop doing that you know you can't get
koala bears sliders but you can [ __ ]
get as much sushi as you [ __ ] want
because everybody's trying to get abs
you know I think a lot of that fish
[ __ ] died because they committed
suicide after they swam by that [ __ ]
kid rape island that they're not going
to do a [ __ ] thing about unbelievable
un-fuckin'-believable the [ __ ] you can
get away with when you got a little bit
of loot well if we expose this ring of
pedophiles we won't get to do an
interview with the prince and princess
you know there you go ladies huh you
still like to watch you a dumb TV there
you go that's what that gets you they
don't go after pedophiles because you
guys are keeping up with the kardashians
yes I just made that leap
um oh look at this somebody just texted
me just read that Trump will be at the
LSU Alabama game Bama released us
letters stating hold on let's see what's
going on here
dude don't run he's like a wrestler how
polarizing this [ __ ] guy is anyone
engaging in disruptive behavior will be
removed for the remainder of the season
yeah this guy's a [ __ ] lunatic man
did you see that I guess a couple years
ago some chick on a bicycle gave the
finger to his motorcade and then she
ended up getting fired Oh [ __ ] funny
is that it's like fired for what you
were on your own time I'm assuming you
were on your own bicycle isn't that part
of this country that's what's great back
in the day you couldn't give a finger to
[ __ ] Hitler you couldn't give the
finger to [ __ ] Stalin they'd pull
over and they'd sawed it off and shove
it up your ass that would be yet
I thought that that's what made this
country great you could [ __ ] give
give the head guy yeah go [ __ ] yourself
and they're like afraid of a speech I
like that you're exercising it mr.
president I'll look into that see it for
years ha ha right the [ __ ] politician
thing now with this regime she end up
getting fired how the [ __ ] did that go
down so then she gets fired and now
she's running for office and of course
she gets [ __ ] elected because this
guy's so polarizing not cuz she's
necessarily gonna do a good [ __ ] job
I think it's cuz she's a lady and she
was wrong did they did she was wronged
unlike those you know those kids on that
[ __ ] kid rape island evidently that's
fine evidently you know nothing to see
there that was just a moment a private
moment of frustration actually you know
what I believe her because when I
watched that first thing I believe that
she was frustrated that she didn't she
didn't get the exclusive
she's like ah you know it's so
frustrating like the emotion wasn't
there she should have been like a kid I
[Music]
mean what am i working for here these
people it wasn't that you just like oh I
had it and they just they just wouldn't
[ __ ] shower because they wanted her
to interview Prince Harry and look
[ __ ] her Jesus Christ don't say why
can't everybody just be perfect like me
okay let's do what we let's do well
let's do some reads here simply safe you
know people according to the FBI the
average loss in a burglary is over two
thousand what are they doing that math
for when they could have gone to that
[ __ ] island and stopped what was
going on but even so only one in five
homes have home security exclamation
point
most companies really don't make it easy
but simply safe is different simply safe
protection your whole home unlike those
other places they they'll protect part
of it alright what room do you jerk up
in okay well get some security every
window room indoor with 24/7 monitoring
for just a fraction of the cost their
police dispatch is up to three and a
half times faster than the other
companies because simply safe uses video
verification where does that video where
does that take place does it take place
outside your house and they videotape
the [ __ ] person coming in the window
or they videotaping you while you're
having Thanksgiving dinner waiting for
some crook to come in that's what I
would look up there's no contract hidden
fees or fine print this system is
designed to blend right into your home
no wires no drilling it's easy to order
and easy to set up usually in under an
hour well that's nice
simply safe has won a ton of awards from
CNET to new york times why Akata
prices are always fair and honest
around-the-clock monitoring
just $15 a month visit simply safe bird
calm you'll get free shipping and a
60-day risk-free trial be sure to go to
simply safe bird comm so they know our
show sent you that's simply safe s impl
I sa Fe bird comm all right I'll butcher
box everybody stop eating fish they're
all gone but we keep growing cows and
chickens okay we keep going the pigs
butcher bucks you know when it comes to
me
quality matters there's more to it than
just texture and taste every month
butcher buck ships a curated selection
of high-quality meat right to my home
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones each box has nine to
eleven pounds of meat enough for 24
individual sized meals unless you're on
that [ __ ] Island and you're tired
from exerting yourself holding those
kids down then you know you probably
need 25 pounds Oh bill packed fresh and
ship frozen and vacuum sealed so it
stays that way I can customize my box or
go with one of theirs either way get
exactly what you want you know in the
future when they have those sex robots
that sentence I can customize my box is
gonna mean something completely
different
my favorite is the heritage breed pork I
told you it's the best pork chop I've
ever had
butcher box is a no-brainer it's the
best meat shipped right to my dua which
means one less trip to the grocers well
I was have to go back to get a side dish
donut I mean I don't know about you guys
when I go grocery shopping I get it all
at once but what it does mean is that I
have to stand behind that [ __ ]
stuttering jackass at the [ __ ] meat
counter it does mean that I can just go
in I can get my [ __ ] sauces I can get
my greens I can get in I can get out
with bunch of bucks you get the highest
quality meat for around four around just
but six bucks a meal options like 100%
grass-fed finished beef free-range
organic chicken fly chicken fly heritage
breed pork wild-caught alaskan salmon
you don't know what and sugar and
nitrate-free bacon it's the way meat
should
right now you can get two pounds of
ground beef and two packs of bacon
absolutely free plus $20 on your first
box just go to butcher box com / / use
the promo code at bar at checkout
that's butcher box calm or use promo
code burr at checkout righty then
okay let's see what the Donald is up to
I'm rooting for that guy man I hope he
has a good heart I hope he he hope he's
doing something you know what I mean
I'd love to hear what he thinks about
that [ __ ] pedophile island over there
well you know there's two sides to every
story you know you can see both sides of
neo-nazis I mean you know well I mean
everybody has you know their version of
the fender bender he was not seek
heiling he he was cracking his elbow Oh
Donald Google nose here we go
who do you got you know I'm so excited
for this [ __ ] LSU Alabama game this
is the best shot LSU has had probably
since [ __ ] Nick Saban was been there
I hate to say it since he was coaching
LSU last time they played Alabama I
would say let's actually look it up man
let's take a look here let's take a look
see that's when that's what's a teacher
says in a class you [ __ ] hate open
your books and let's take a look-see to
chapter 8 and let's just get more into
this subject that you have no interest
in whatsoever all right
last time LSU beat Alabama comes right
up well it wasn't [ __ ] last year 29
nothing they lost when was the last when
is the last time
LSU beat Alabama in football why can't
they just answer the question the LSU
vs. Alabama football game Saturday
renewed one of the most finally shut the
[ __ ] up that okay alright where are we
okay the last time LSU beat Alabama in
football was the 2011 regular season
that year the Tigers topped the Crimson
Tide in the regular season on November
5th by score by a score of 9 to 6
both teams qualified for the BCS
National Championship game and Alabama
won the rematch 21 nothing so they won
the one that counted
LSU finished the season 13 and 1 under
coach Les Miles that grass eatin crazy
sumbitch Alabama ended as the champion
with the 12 and 1 mark under coach Nick
Saban right well so we have not beat
them an eight straight [ __ ]
regular-season games and I think it's
time for a change I don't know they got
the [ __ ] quarterback they got the
defense they got everything going about
Alabama's just [ __ ] oh they're so
fast they don't look like a college
goddamn team but how great would that be
though for them to go into Alabama with
all those arrogant people from Alabama
just sitting there looking down on
Mississippi ignoring the jeers from
Georgia that's how it works
east to west georgia looks down on
Alabama Alabama looks down on
Mississippi and everybody [ __ ] [ __ ]
in New Orleans that is the south okay
any Europeans listening to this if
you're on your way over here and you
want to know you know do you want to go
to the smartest state along the redneck
Riviera you go to Georgia this is
according to Southern people okay and
then Alabama you know that's if you got
some feelings for someone who might be a
little too closely related to you you
going a little great balls of fire there
right and then if you're just like I
don't know
inbred you're in Mississippi now these
are these are not my beliefs people
these are just things that were told to
me by southerners about their own people
okay and this is why we won the Civil
War the
because there's so much infighting
amongst the states right the reality is
is a true southerner knows he's not as
smart as a Yankee he just knows that you
know they might have been back in the
day but after they lost the war all the
good books went up north okay and then
they got the bad books so it's not that
they're dumb it's that they lost the
Civil War and they know that that was
the big turning point for them which is
why to this day they still say things
like the south is gonna rise again and
blah blah blah because they they want
like a rematch and the North has been
like Floyd Mayweather in the last
[ __ ] half of his career where he
wouldn't fight anybody you know so we
don't want that rematch we're going to
kick your ass we just had well we're
moving on we're done we took one plug
the [ __ ] PlayStation and we went home
and they're still sitting there and
their [ __ ] parents finished basement
waiting for a rematch that is never
gonna happen it's just not happening you
know so I guess you know if you're an
American and you want to be smart you
got to get above the mason-dixon line
okay and all you need to do is listening
to this podcast to hear the far superior
public education that I got while I was
up north you can hear it in the way my
ideas you can hear it in the way I read
out loud you know the way that I think I
can sing right all right let's let's
start some [ __ ] here what do you think
is the dumbest state in the US I want I
want your submissions okay and you can't
just name a [ __ ] state because their
team always kicks your ass all right I
want reasons okay I need three good
reasons that whatever state you're
nominating is the dumbest [ __ ] state
in the Union all right I'll go first let
me see let me just see here dumbest
[ __ ] state
well I want to say California cuz I live
there so right there that's a strike
against them I would say the craziest
[ __ ] like what is going on in what is
in the water part of the country that
I've ever been in was western
Pennsylvania you know I'm not talking
Pittsburgh you get outside of Pittsburgh
and you go north and you could shoot
[ __ ] deliverance up there I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on there's a
just a couple of places where I got out
of my car I mean I went into a Wendy's
and there was a black chick behind the
[ __ ] register wearing Rouge and I was
just like what the [ __ ] you know that
was the first these people were a little
off and then I remember one time I was
driving from where the [ __ ] was I going
Jesus Christ I think I had done Bob and
Tom and then I was driving south was i
driving over to nashville was i going
down to atlanta i was in either the
southern I think the southern part of
Kentucky or the southern part of
Tennessee and I got out of the [ __ ]
car
at this gas station first of all gas was
like a dollar thirty because nobody had
any [ __ ] money
it was [ __ ] something like that it
was nuts and just like like southerners
that would offend southerners if they
were in a Hollywood movie going like we
ain't like that like [ __ ] walking
around with big gulps and [ __ ] no
teeth and [ __ ] it just like going like
wow what the like it's this a pivotal
point that you get when you get in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere where you're
between two major cities that have jobs
in
books but these people live just past
the gravitational pull of either city
and they're just out there floating and
decades go by and nothing is done for
these people and they just they just
sort of slip off into their own [ __ ]
deal it's fascinating it's really
fascinating so I don't really have I
don't have a particular state come on
bill is you start in the [ __ ] game
you got a pick a state let me see here
problem is I met a lot of nice people
out there all right I'm gonna go
Pennsylvania I'm gonna go Pennsylvania
because of western Pennsylvania and the
caricature that Philly fans have become
well now they just do crazy [ __ ] cuz
they're supposed to do crazy [ __ ] it's
like watching Buffalo Bill fence it's
like oh we break tables okay now how do
we take this to the next level so I can
be the gal gets Instagram hits my most
respect is for West Coast fans because
they will actually take a jail sentence
and kill you
why am I starting [ __ ] cuz it's fun all
right
then for Europe you have to go most
arrogant country what country I don't
you know what this so [ __ ] up over
there I don't want to start I don't get
this them going again because you can
feel it's starting again you know it
actually made me feel like you know one
World Bank might not be a bad thing just
because these [ __ ] people would then
have a common enemy you know it's kind
of like when the Eastern Bloc when
Russia was controlling all of Eastern
Europe they had a common enemy and they
kind of squashed all this [ __ ] and then
when Russia left or collapsed whatever
the [ __ ] you want to say then all of
that all of those fights Bosnian Serbs
Croatians and all those that [ __ ] just
picked right back I'd never heard nobody
ever heard of it
it picked up they were just like and
where were we
and they went right back the [ __ ] in
yeah Europe's a tough place man that's
just too many tribes it's tribal over
there I mean they're too [ __ ] close
together cuz they was [ __ ] and and
building up their tribes back before any
sort of crazy public transportation so
back in the day Poland was way the [ __ ]
away from Germany you never went there
your whole [ __ ] life and now you can
get in India you know on the Autobahn
alright you get on their Drive like a
[ __ ] zillion meters a mile
whatever an hour whatever the [ __ ] they
call it over there and you're in Poland
and then they got all this back
[ __ ] history with each other back
trace it and they give each other's [ __ ]
Nixie no it's all starting up again you
know and meanwhile people are going to
this [ __ ] Island banging kids and
they had the whole story and nobody
seems to give a [ __ ] during the the me
to movement well that was on an island
and nobody who did it had a television
show so it's not interesting to the me
to movement it's not something that is
on our radar hey somebody just is gonna
be a puppeteer on a puppet show
let's vet him let's find it what kind of
a [ __ ] person he is before he puts
his toxic [ __ ] hand up that puppets
non-existent [ __ ] alright
that's the podcast here everybody any
aspiring [ __ ] creeps out there you
need to get your own Island evidently
and get some rich friends to come over
there and participate in whatever the
[ __ ] it is you're doing and the whole
thing will go away enjoy the music enjoy
your weekend you [ __ ] and here's uh and
after the music there'll be another
bonus Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast all right
let's go LSU bad
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast from
Monday November 7th 2011
how the hell are you guys yeah did you
have a great week well that's that's
fascinating
actually had a brutal day yesterday of
watching football and I have a big time
guest this week so I won't really get
into it I'm just gonna throw this out
here and I want to hear your guys
responses over the week I believe
personally if Dan Marino still played in
the league he would throw for [ __ ]
6,000 yards all right I've had it you
can't even cover [ __ ] receivers I saw
it during the Ravens game and all that
type but I'm not bitching about the
Patriots at all congratulations to the
Giants the Patriots defense is even
worse than last year and at this point I
think the Jets are gonna win the
division
I think they beat us next week and I
don't know there's only so far throwing
the football could get you if you can't
stop it on the other end so that's it
all right so anyways this is the podcast
for this week as mentioned very special
guests here to hype his brand-new show a
good friend of mine I toured with him
earlier this year I believe he called in
on podcast
well King and welcoming him back can't
even sit welcoming him back please
welcome mr. Dave Attell everybody Billy
thanks for having me thank you for being
here David it's it's an honor to be here
on the Monday morning podcast you know
it's the afternoon right now you
basically that's the [ __ ] email I get
every week what did you call it the
[ __ ] - why don't you go [ __ ] yourself
I had a rough time not saying you I'm
talking about the listen why did you
call it sometime Monday podcast because
for the most part I get it I get it up
on Monday morning how about that for the
most part well in the morning bill does
this like is this your studio or is this
like just like one of your many safe
houses that you use this underground
podcast this is one of my safe houses
whenever I do I don't actually have a
guest in mm-hmm I actually come here
because it's gonna actually sound like a
radio show we're supposed to
my little gadget read that I bought at
Guitar Center which is okay really but
it's really been on the fritz lately and
people don't give a [ __ ] when it's just
me you know I don't know you know if you
look to my IMDB page Dave I'm when I'm
at the premium blend level no I'm saying
no do it your your so under under
selling yourself because I think on imbd
you went up you want to pass Scott
Bakula right now because of the breaking
bad dude
every white guy's fantasy I've never
been jealous of anybody acting because I
think acting is a little fruit a but
when you were on that show which is my
favorite show I was like yes that's
great great very nice and my acting you
didn't think was fruit a on that's not
at all now that I know is pure can I
curse on your yeah that's pure [ __ ]
man that show that I didn't think my
beard was trimmed just a little too well
why didn't I don't have a HD I didn't
know I don't look at that cool
but you knew your lines and they were
pretty they were pretty complicated he
has been giving me [ __ ] lately saying
that I look like the gay guy on Modern
Family
oh yeah now you ruined it for me but
that's the coolest show and I know they
do it in Albuquerque and put it back is
the [ __ ] you know you know was I I never
had been to New Mexico and I went out
there was absolutely you know at the
risk of you know this getting a little
gay here considering were a couple of
guys it was absolutely gorgeous state
you can literally see the weather change
in coming and what's crazy No Country
for Old Men is one of my favorite movies
they did that there they did that there
they actually and of course I didn't
realize that until I left and you know a
lot of that stuff that they shot where
Josh Brolin gets killed in the end
spoiler alert I should have said they
actually shot that right down the street
at least the exterior of it and I'm like
one of those total [ __ ] nerds or I
like I like to drive over to where they
shot something and I like to get sad
when I find out the place where you know
in Reservoir Dogs
you know the morgue where they shot that
doesn't exist anymore when I find out
it's a [ __ ] Home Depot actually gets
sad you know like I was on the shoot or
something
well that's your kink I guess but I'll
tell ya I did Albuquerque a couple
and I shot the insomniac show a long
time ago we did Albuquerque and back
then the town was like I guess you know
it was really kind of like a underground
kind of like off the map kind of town
yeah and we went to a strip club and
then we went back because there was
nothing else open and then it was it was
what right you left the strip club but
yeah back yeah then we had to go back as
it was like nothing else to do and then
the best part was like even the
strippers like which strip and then they
would like just like change and then
they would go back to the strip club
feels like nothing else they needed like
a Danny's I think someplace to go it
hasn't for a lap dance then I'm off yeah
I'm just hanging out you know kind of a
family kind of feel to it but I you know
we got the job done but I really was so
excited to see you on that um on that
thing because I remember when we were on
tour doing the anti-social door Jim yeah
you said you just shot those things the
breaking beds um yeah I had done I did
one in February the one outside the
carwash and then the one where I got to
act like I was actually a tough guy knew
how to fight I did that one shot that
one in May and I was cool that's worked
with lavell Crawford so it's a bunch of
common oh yeah yeah a lot of comics are
on that show and before we get too far
into this I sorry I do want I do want to
hype what we what you got going on here
you have a brand new show call on
Showtime called Dave's old porn
yes which debuted about a week ago um no
bill let's see we're about three weeks
in and it's a great it's yes for a
premium cable it's a hit that's awesome
and a lot of people who are interested
about the Harry 70s early 80s porn of
yesteryear before Twitter I've said this
a million times but before the web and
all that kind of stuff you know old VCR
top-loading you know old porn so what
what just I mean just to let the
listeners at home data just to paint a
picture for them what exactly tell us
about the show without spoiling
basically what I was on well it's kind
of the Mystery Science Theater of porn
where I bring out comics like this week
this Thursday at 11:30 on Showtime bill
burr himself will be there that's right
and we will be sampling
jumping
clip the clip through nina hartley who
is a probably one of the greatest living
legends of porn nina hartley a delight
super cool lady and we watch her clips
did you have fun watching her stuff yeah
I was I was absolutely starstruck that
she showed up yeah yeah believe it i sat
on a couch was me Nina and Dave watching
and literally watching old porn and
sitting there commenting on it and I
thought she was cool as hell I was
really uh like definitely I don't know
like just she I don't know porn starts
they just don't judge anything when
you've just gone through all of that
stuff they've done they're just kind of
like hey you know whatever there's I
freaked out at one point you had you
don't give it away no I'm not I'm Joe
seing a little bit of that clip this
week on Dave's own 4.com yeah these are
what I realized is that like first of
all watching porn with women is
different than watching porn with two
it's like you know sausagefest bachelor
party you know watch a couple of stag
films get drunk everyone with their legs
crossed right hard-on right exactly we
brought out some of the funniest ladies
two ladies Whitney Cummings Chelsea
Handler Margaret Cho and it's cool
watching with a woman cuz they get the
woman's perspective on sex and porn and
the whole thing and they like it but
they don't like it like we like it you
know right that actually and that
immediately was fascinating to me what
what did you find was different well
they definitely do not like double
penetration anal donkey punch any kind
of any kind of jizz you know G which we
call facials and money shots all that
stuff is really not in their bucket list
stuff I hope one day to do this with my
pressure
it all depends on I think for most women
that is like that but then every once in
a while yeah you'll meet a real
thoroughbred and they'll actually be
will it be the way you do yes it's hard
to tie actually I actually saw I was
messing around this girl a long time ago
and I won't watch one of those max
hardcores yes I love that guy yeah and
they were and I remember saying to a
like yeah you're not gonna want my point
I'm watching at this point it's really
twisted you don't want to watch this
[ __ ] and she says like now get put
let's like put it on and and she was
actually I actually got self-conscious
as I shut it off and I was like I can't
watch this with you yeah you feel bad no
and then she was just like what she you
know what did she say she said she
wanted it is the way she said it which
was just the classic accused lied and I
had a lot of fun with that girl Dave oh
good you know I really did you're an
honest unassuming type so I never even
thought you like porn because I figured
cuz some of it I don't think you really
understood what we were doing but then I
think once you got into it you really
like you know dug in and I like that
because at first we were watching this
movie that Nina made with Tracy Adams
who's another legend of porn called the
ultimate lover with Erik headboards and
it's kind of a Frankenstein esque film
and we try and jump through the whole
film it was really difficult wasn't it
to watch an entire movie yeah I mean
like you never do that in real life
watch a whole porn from beginning to end
just go right to the point yeah exactly
fast-forward or whatever is you know the
phone rings or your boss walks in it so
you know that what about I got this way
I think it's it's the being raised
Catholic thing yeah it's like is crass
as I am on on this podcast all the [ __ ]
that I say and some of the stuff I talk
about on stage you know I curse a lot
but I do stay away from sex for some
reason or good god I can say [ __ ] on
stage I can do all that type I trash
women misogynistic stuff arguably I
don't think so I think I have a point
but but for some reason without if I
talk about sex on stage I'm always
really self-conscious and I feel like
I'm being crass I don't know why
internet and I'm not judging someone who
talks about sex is just personally I
think it has to do with that that that's
sort of upbringing so probably the
episode I did with you though that was
the initial you know going out god I'm
talking about this this is on TV because
I had no idea what the show was yeah how
hardcore you were gonna do it or the way
you guys were gonna edit around stuff
which I saw a clip which is [ __ ]
genius by the way I think it's really
funny and we floating on the couch hey
Bill man you're three weeks in no I'm
sorry I'm like Lucas I don't want to
give away
Giorgio's we're working with an actual
comedian and a human being and not
having me digitally put in there oh yeah
exactly well let me tell you something
it rocked out because we had the gut we
had great comics like you and Jim Norton
and Adam Carolla and this was Norton's
aired yet no not yet but God Norton to
porn is like he's the Sacagawea he could
find the three way he could find the
three way at a church picnic I mean he
is the best I mean he really like gets
into it we have these great close-ups of
him but I could see for yourself like a
great analyst on ESPN except yes porn
that's why I 101 that's why I was asking
I when is Jim's like I got it Jim's is
coming out he's towards the end of the
run but right now last week's show for
those who did watch and I think your
crowd kind of would dig this like the
people listen his podcasts market is old
porn well-known was the young porn stars
belladonna Christina rose
Bobby star watching the old retro Harry
porn and you'll never believe this bill
but they found a quaint they were like
look at this this is adorable hair they
didn't really dig but they liked hair a
little bit but but the sex they were
like look how adorable they're cuddling
and kissing they don't do that in
today's porn it's really like like you
said it in the show I'm not gonna give
it away but it's like a workout it's
like like a p90x video it's like yeah
[ __ ] hardcore and extreme so no no no
no but I got a Lhasa on a podcast to
talk too much not at all okay no but you
got to give me credit being 15 minutes
in and I've yet to go so Dave what is
the inspiration for you did you always
want him what were some of the jobs you
had before I don't think we've said this
yet Thursday 11:30 on Showtime Dave's
old porn the new hit show
yeah well it's a hit it's doing really
well it's right after gigolos which is
about a couple of male escorts rightly
there you go
it's the late-night block and then the
Twitter account is at old porn in these
the the letter O in porn is actually not
the letter O it's it's the it's zeros
yeah number zero because that's Twitter
but let me tell you this bill if they go
to the Dave's old point com website
they'll be able to see pictures and
clips of upcoming shows your share will
be this Thursday and other stuff that we
have shot so but it's really
it's what you say like how did I come up
with the idea it's like I've been
working on this idea for like four years
I think I've told this to you like three
or four times I want to say drunkenly
whatever is over this like a year ago
didn't yeah I shot something yeah we
shot this last summer and it took so
long to edit because it's all about
post-production you saw and but besides
that like I've been working on it for
years and years and I came up with the
idea it was co-created by a Stewart B I
don't use his last name because he is in
television but Stewart Bailey and he
he's helped you know helped me shape and
guide it and like Showtime is the best
place work because you know we're
allowed to show everything up to
penetration so everybody's not grain
yeah and I thought when I was and
there's always the one guys like where's
the penetration it's like I'm with you
dude I'm totally with this guy it's like
I feel like I cannot save this man you
know it's like oh you got it I love porn
so but what you're doing is you're kind
of doing it the way they do movie
trailers right now yes when they show a
movie trailer they show the entire movie
except for the basically the conclusion
of the third act they show you right up
until how the hero solves right and I
think that that's what you're doing with
porn yes if you actually showed the
penetration then there's no point you
want people to laugh you know um people
rubbing one out as they're watching it
I'd like I'd like a little both I'd like
people to go like you know that was
funny and now I'm hard what do I do you
know like that kind of a thing this dog
runs out of the room you know it's how
you pitched the show and you came in I'm
a great pitcher Bill you never give me
credit for this but I'm a great pitcher
even on the anti-social so roots both
talking about ideas you remember that
that one time we ran into each other we
it was for a pilot right and you got the
pilot remember it was like what yeah
pushing the guy through the wheel check
with the wheelchair oh yeah yeah and I
was reading this one I was like this is
a really funny show and then like I say
either I'm like oh this guy is the guy
to do it and I think you got that that
show I don't know I I think I think I'm
a good actor if somebody gives me a
chance to I'm not the greatest
auditioners all right miss stop crying
audition our audition
are you are you a trained actor or are
you just like just from growing up in
Boston everybody's like either I just
took acting classes from the
we help these three jobs in Boston bank
robber unappreciated boxer and then of
course AK Ben Affleck I think is made
out to two out of those three movies
what a hard-on you mister got watching
that here in that Southie accent treat
harsh where she action getting a little
it's getting a little cartoonish at this
point I don't know if it's that it's
just that when you say like for years
people ask me where am i from and I
would always say Boston because I
wouldn't say the suburb up front because
then it becomes like a we like you know
the suburb nobody knows it's just I'm
just trying to get through that part of
the conversation but then after like the
Good Will Hunting and all that if you
say you're from Boston people like
Southie you from Southie then you gotta
be back now I so what I always say now
is I am from these safe suburbs of South
Boston that's what I smoke but even that
if you say boss and they go did you know
someone who robbed a bank and then you
cut kept your mouth shut
you know can I get me a pistol you know
what's funny is I drank in a lot of
those areas yeah I never saw any of that
going on
I read that law Southie and I was like
wow that's crazy
and I would ask Greg Fitzsimmons who's
also from Boston he's from upstate New
York is he he but he grew up you know
Maddie would be if I said upstate New
York he keep bristles alright well he
was on he's on my show too
alright so he's on he did a great job
also but I wanted to say that Boston
definitely has like the comics like you
know louis c.k Nick DiPaolo and he's
just the young guys and then they have
like that whole generation of like you
know stephen wright and all those guys
yeah I'm from Long Island we got like
Seinfeld Kevin James Jeffy Jeff Jeff EJ
I know it goes really quickly into
comedy hypnotism but now there's a
couple of Eddie Murphy of course we've
got some pretty good guys
yeah no longer look got a bunch of guys
yeah or the whole like New York area but
well you know Long Island comics were
different oh there's another bad
question I could have asked you Dave I
mean you're just part of this long
lineage of comedians that's just come
out of Long Island was there something
in the water I mean talk about what was
it like little fun we never drank water
seltzer you see we're Jews and it's
immediately the podcast level in town
Jews I
[ __ ] hate Jews huh no no I don't know
prom with them every once in a while
though you'll meet one yeah and you're
like that's how it happened
that's how our vine this weekend I was
like any Jews here none any Persians a
lot dude how about the [ __ ] plastic
surgery down there is that out of
control there's some really hot chicks
up there man that was the filthiest year
I've done in a long time let me tell you
the lineup bill okay it was me Yoshi you
know Yoshi right very very funny guy
Asian I met him in Vegas yeah yeah Yoshi
this kid Chris Neff Jason from Canada do
you know him
he's very dirty too his name is he's
very funny guy Jason Jason color or
scholar says oh so very very funny guy
really I'm sorry there was so many
openers I'm saying and Shaun rouse who's
probably one of the filthiest what guys
with rheumatoid arthritis he's very sad
so like you look at this a character but
yet he's filthy dirty and then the girls
too were pretty you know filthy to a
Rosie and Jen and out of the crowd take
it they love it by the time I got up
there I was like you know like like Will
Rogers ya know there's like not one
[ __ ] joke left I was talking about
taint for like 40 minutes balloon
animals yeah it was really it was it's
it's like one of those things like I
understand it's really hard to like have
you know to find a comic that'll have
filthy comedy with him because like all
these you know crowds is so PC now that
like my crowd is cool and they dig it
but it really was like too many too many
animals on the ark if you ask me I you
know we needed definitely one guy to
like break it up with yeah but they got
a lovely magic when you come to town not
only do you have one of the best acts
ever of course and I know you hate
taking common guys were great i trouble
following them but you you know you also
sell a bunch of tickets and then they
drink a lot that's like I drew that is
the that right there's the trifecta
that's true listening to his act a bunch
of people show up and they'd a empty the
bar they are great drugs to my crowd
they're like professional drunk so back
in the day when they were all like
truckers and you know like just like
crazy
Nomad type people now
like adults with their wives and
whatever it's weird to see them but
they've they've had they've aged nicely
I'd say I'm headed to Phoenix to that
new club do you know this place oh is
that the one what's-his-face
Dan opened up yeah I think so it's it's
not The Improv but the other one the
Phoenix store but it's in fear Heights
that day wanting people the people are
listening after you watch Dave's old
porn 11:30 on Showtime Thursday night
where can they see what what weekend
you're gonna be out there net this
weekend so what is this weekend yeah
very nice and it's today Veterans Day I
don't think so okay well it's coming up
so definitely that Veterans Day was in
it's Memorial Day know the Memorial Day
Flag days in June let's just go through
the months I think I think we're coming
up on Veterans Day so a big shout out to
the troops and I'll do it again okay and
again again again dude I gotta get over
there thank you very
know what I like about you bill very
little merch we were all hanging out on
the anti social tour you had like you
haven't written a book yet I don't
believe I don't believe in selling them
[ __ ] that that doesn't have jokes on it
right so that's I'm not saying books are
bad but like I'm not into the t-shirt
thing and the hats and all that type of
you know but that's for a TV show that's
different that's a badass hat - yeah
they come in kids sizes also they born
see if I really was a [ __ ] of merch I
would be like okay we got this in this
and it but you know what people don't
have the money for merch at least from
my merch like if you're like a southern
guy or something people buy anything a
lunch bone that that dead let's talk
about that store okay on that tour there
was so much [ __ ] March I mean Jim
Norton at this point has more books than
like [ __ ] Stephen King but he has
like for Cersei he's got three full
novels yeah that he's written yeah he's
got like I don't know two three specials
hmm and it was just there was so much
miniature yeah it was and then this
shirt that we made for the tour I
finally just [ __ ] said oh by the way I
never got any if I never got a [ __ ]
dime for that did you ever get anything
no I haven't got any of that stuff
either
it's it's it's somewhere out there I
don't know I'm still calculating it I
mean when was our last date oh yeah add
it up but the shows were good but for
some reason like you know I said like
casinos this is a casino show we're like
like Zeppelin in the 80s like people
will come to a casino and [ __ ] see us
rock out our greatest hit but then we
tried to do all these other venues that
was that was rough but Chicago I thought
that they just they they went they went
too too big too quick by said that too
but I think tickets were too much - yeah
audience but that [ __ ] show was
ridiculous it's a great show I thought
yeah I'm just for people who uh who were
new to my podcasts I did this tour Jim
Norton put it together the antisocial
Network tour earlier this year it was it
was Dave Attell Jim Norton
Jim Breuer and myself all gracing the
same stage the fact that I you're too
big to do it the fact that we didn't
come out and sing songs
yes afterwards would have been
tremendous and you guys are you guys
have a new lineup yes is you Jim Norton
Doug Stanhope Doug Stanhope and and
Artie Lange's gonna do a date or two
yeah well I think I'm gonna buy a ticket
to that without us bill I mean see see
did we we loved having you but let's
face it we have to go with the filthiest
dirtiest guys who are not acting on
Breaking Bad right now we're not waiting
to hear from Tom Hanks on a movie no no
I'm gonna be back on that tour at some
point I know absolutely you're always
well I'm back I just I'm getting ready
to do another special so I had to be go
out there running my mouth for a little
over an hour just so I absolutely stay
in shape for those types of things but
uh how's that gone along with the
material and everything I got it to the
point where I definitely have this
special
I just gotta polish up a couple of
things and and just you know you know
that deal it's like you put out a
special and then you you want to do one
that's as good if not better and then
you also want it to be like a little bit
different so you know I'm kind of
pushing myself to try and do [ __ ] that I
kind of knew I could do on stage like so
what I do [ __ ] like when I Drive around
with my girl like well I'll imitate a
conversation but I'll only do my half of
it but why what I'm saying you can
understand what the other person saying
okay let's try it now I'll be your girl
I'm just saying that's one of the things
I've been I've been trying to work on so
and I haven't done that the other ones
just to give it something a little bit
different because there's two schools of
thought you can do the ACDC thing will
you sing about the devil your balls and
[ __ ] I like that and you just keep
doing it and do it and doing it and this
is what we do go [ __ ] yourselves yes or
you can try to like change up and every
once in a while you have a big Miss and
everybody's like what the [ __ ] you doing
you know you grow yeah you save the
growth you have your u2 moment where you
gonna make bug-eyed [ __ ] sunglasses
you do a special like that I have no
shirt on underneath you're like you're
like well who would it be what would be
the Steven Tyler what's this man again I
would be the Hootie and the Blowfish no
come on
like they they did like so many albums
and then like you know it's like they
were like hot and then they would like
have to like restart again they're like
an amazing [ __ ] band yeah it's
ridiculous
no and then they went through this this
whole that is Boston - yeah we're uh
Steven Tyler fell off the wagon again so
fell off the wagon they actually
considered going solo at 61 years of age
amazing which would have been I think
that that would have beat George Foreman
winning the heavyweight title at 46 I
give you that I don't know how these
guys can tour like that even though
their tour is like an amazing like a you
know like buses and private jets and all
that kind of [ __ ] butts though it's
still touring and like you know just
like just the amount of like people that
must have to like be on the tour like
you know publicist and like you know
nannies for all the you know third wife
children and you know just weird just
right of all your scarves yeah exactly
just like horribly you know like like
it's traveling army basically like
Spartacus with a and also musicians when
they go on the road they go on the road
like the way we go on the road is like
you know we go out for four days come
back a bag yeah yeah go back like those
guys were like what the [ __ ] was Irene
about recently world tour yeah somebody
went out I was on yet another flight and
I was reading about the piano player or
something for the Rolling Stones and he
was talking about he was into trees no
really that's how long this flight was
we were in like a holding pattern over
LAX I'm reading about this [ __ ] guy
how he's into trees somehow but he was
talking how they did like I eat they
were like 18 months straight on the
[ __ ] Road oh my god Wow really gauge
it out ever coming home that's how
that's how it's written Wow
like I don't get how you just you just
leave and you never come back because
I'm kind of on this this brutal stretch
here where I did the I did a tour
through Europe mmm and you know that dad
the flight going over is exciting
because this is the anticipation but
coming back it's like you know give a
[ __ ] you just want to get home and
you're going against the Gulfstream or
whatever so it's like five years five
extra [ __ ] hours and supposed to have
a weekend off and luckily something came
up and I had to go to New York and I got
to tell you just like I'm such a [ __ ]
compared to those guys that well I'm
talking three weeks out like I I hated
my life I hated the sound of my [ __ ]
voice where was this in England or where
were you I went to uh I did one night in
London and then I went through
Scandinavia I did copenhagen oslo
stockholm and then which isn't part of
scandinavia I learned is actually
considered one of the Nordic countries
Finland I did Helsinki which you would
have [ __ ] you would have loved
Helsinki why I would love it because
you're an intelligent man you like to
travel you're interesting you find
people interesting I do like a lot of
people know that about you you are a
[ __ ] people person like when we
visited the veterans in when we were all
at the Pentagon right and we're walking
in there and there's these kids and they
you know they suffered those horrible
horrible injuries and I remember all of
us on the tour was standing there like
wanting to say something not know what
to say and you just you just walked
right in like you know you just like
you've known him yay a whole lot and I
gotta be honest too when I was in there
I just followed your lead no you gotta
yeah it's a very difficult situation
when you go visit the wounded soldiers
but they really you got to think of it
from their perspective they're just in a
constant state of like rehabilitation
you know they're young a lot of them are
really young they're like trying to
figure out what they're going to do with
it's such a horrible horrible situation
each one of them you know their parents
sometimes their parents are with them
and the parents don't know what to do
and it's like anybody who's who's
who's who's sick but then some I mean
you know you're it's really hard to not
just break down but you got to like you
know power root for these dudes and they
love that you came and ya up the
monotony of them and you'll never forget
it and hopefully you know it helped them
pass the time so yeah you were like
chillin you were [ __ ] hilarious you
going in you know just doing those those
[ __ ] oh they love it yeah yeah so
that was the thing I don't go through
all that [ __ ] and not come out be
realized that God has a sense of [ __ ]
humor I mean really honestly yeah and I
wanted to make sure that I went in there
that I wasn't looking at him like like
what you wouldn't want to sit there
being a [ __ ] it was that lying you
had to walk like yeah you know I respect
what you done but I don't sit there look
at you like you this pity case they are
and I don't want to treat you like a
regular [ __ ] person but then that be
so regular that I'm disrespectful so I'm
Tony I just I just like the Tour de
France I just drafted behind you and I
watched you go to a couple of tables and
I've kind of figured out what I was
gonna do and now I saw everybody do that
and everybody after a while Norton
Brewer all this sudden yell the sudden I
saw all in them were going around the
room and then one like within 20 minutes
it's like you didn't want to leave it
was really man that tour was [ __ ]
awesome and yeah that was great and then
we get we we gave him tickets and a lot
of them came to the show and that's
really cool too because yeah first of
all like they're stuck in this hospital
and they want to get out a lot of them
like can't drink or whatever cuz they're
on these heavy-duty meds that you and I
can only drink a dream of amazing
medication like like Conrad Murray type
[ __ ] medication and you know they
finally get a night out and they're like
young dudes they want to laugh and you
know have a good time get laid you know
what but they got a wake because they're
on this you know they're you know
getting better so that was great that we
did that that was the highlight of the
tour I think for all of us that we got
to go to the Pentagon you know yeah that
was a couple pictures you know I love
you know I like to when you go to the
Pentagon is how they have like that how
unimpressive it is what are you going in
this it's sort of like a mall and yeah
they have like like a gift shop and they
have like ATMs I'm probably the doors
gonna get kicked open from you talking
about the inner levels I also found it
fascinating that nobody really knew how
many floors there were nobody really
knew where anything was and there was
like and then you'd meet that one guy
who had like all this [ __ ] all over his
shirt and you'd be like okay this guy
know somebody he's got all these medals
didn't you think that like we were
like that's like the Pentagon that like
everyone thinks is the Pentagon but then
like deep below it like whatever like a
hundred million feet is like the real
like you know that's a nerve center like
that's the old paranoid pothead and me
thinking there's got to be something
yeah it's kind of like wargames cuz they
have like a like a coffee place and a
gift shop and all that kind of stuff and
you know you don't you never hear that
in these movies like get down to the
gift shop pick up a magnet let's make
this happen
yeah but you know is get me a latte and
a refrigerator magnet of Lincoln yeah
but I was cracking up cuz I went in
there and all of us went in there and
like with like total tourists oh I
remember Brewer going cuz his dad's a
world war two vast is something going on
my dad would love this and I'm buying
like [ __ ] magnets no one's got like
dude it's a [ __ ] Pentagon it's so
cool because like it's all government
[ __ ] so the change is hot right off the
mint do you know I've been trying to do
a mint joke like do you have a joke like
that that you've like you love you've
been trying to do the joke like for
years and years you it's like either you
have the setup or you have the punchline
but like it just like a sticks it's like
it's like I got it yes some always want
to change joke up like cuz I love change
like you know go to the mant you know
either nothing's coming out the economy
sucks or like it's really hot like right
off the press yeah you gotta do
something about a guy who's so like
hooked up in the banking system that
like alright yeah it's gonna be
political yeah when he gave me like 50
cents back or something it was still hot
it was like I had that chuckle he goes
like I go to the US Mint and like I buy
t-shirt and I gave him a 20 and they
couldn't find change it was like well
look around it's the minute yeah I was
like remember that I want to do a mint
joke too I think that's how it started
but anyway oh hey hey that just reminded
me as far as like great jokes I just was
working in st. Louis and I had a local
comedian open up do you know Andy Smith
could because they'd be more female or
no female female oh yeah yeah great oh
yeah yes yes she is a great job Arius
how about the table joke oh yeah I
remember that just I wanted that's yeah
that's the one I quoted i wad up but i
just want to blow up your spot here cuz
i know that you know nobody is great
[ __ ] material but like
she's in st. Louis and uh I worked with
her in Nashville I just was out there I
want to thank everybody by the way who
came out to Cleveland Madison and st.
Louis this weekend I had a [ __ ]
awesome time what I'd like to thank the
vine people and we go look at some
people in the future since I never know
when this Monday - whenever podcast will
add hopefully Patrick here Patrick man
from we're in this apartment from nobody
likes onions podcast one of the original
podcasts by the way by the way he'll be
he'll be the first to tell you okay he
started the whole he's like the Al Gore
of podcast I didn't know that he started
the whole [ __ ] thing no wonder he
looks better I have to say for he's a
single guy right Pat he's swingin man
he's out there he's [ __ ] whatever ins
he's his apartments it's not like a
single guy well the the big screen TV in
the couch really costs that single guy
but it doesn't reek of singleness you
know it's like kind of like vacuumed and
nice I think that's because when the IRS
comes and you just walked in jump on the
podcast giving you props for your moment
we just talked about how clean it was
you literally slim it down a little bit
Patrick Melton everybody do you wear
shoes around your house yeah I do
cuz it's covered in glass and blood and
just sad broken dreams I think you have
wall-to-wall carpeting the reason why
this is so nice I believe is because
it's also a business so he has to make
it look at that we case the IRS kicks
open the door to be there's no
podcasting going on here young man I'm
kind of like an OCD clean but I don't
have a lot of dirt or germs you Larry
I'd make gay hand motions when I speak
that's okay we can but no it is hey that
you have every right to do that
yeah that somebody brings up a gay joke
I just applaud and like tear up because
you know there's no good answer anymore
like you know you can't retort or
anything else you're an [ __ ] there's
little confetti poppers and just no even
that's too many pride parade that's all
that insults them something how far into
this are we like so I can Jeff is trying
time 38 all right use your podcast
usually it's usually an hour long so
here's one for you uh you know believe
it or not somehow I started giving out
advice on my podcast oh yeah don't think
I mean I don't think anybody takes it
seriously but it just so happens Dave
that somebody wrote one in I think you
might be able to help out it uh it has
you know do with porn and that type of
thing and you're here to hype days are
days old porn Emily image come on okay
go ahead Pat you know my energy that's
okay I got smoke at some point I know
there's north non-smoking podcast but go
ahead you can smoke in here so yeah yeah
nobody's do it don't get pissed it'll
remind me my old the old days going to
the hill put on shoes and kick my ass
light up Dave come on telly
alright I respect the man sir
all-weather car yeah yeah
all right advice bill me and Dave will
add that I need your help I dated this
chick and and I feel for I think I love
her
what's wrong with that I feel for you I
think I love you I don't know Bobby
Darin there's no no come on man
it was a tease I'm gonna keep saying
right so you know it I feel I say about
any son Whitesnake I think I love you
what [ __ ] Zod's gonna kill me all
Dave alright uh anyways he said what
split us apart is that she didn't like
porn ah and I promised her I wouldn't
watch it she had self-esteem problems
and like an idiot I broke it I guess he
broke her self-esteem well this guy's
kind of a dick I tried fixing it and for
a while things went back to how they
were but she wanted she wanted a break I
agreed but later she started to like
another guy I didn't like that and tried
to get back with her we had sex and
things were going great I thought
everything would go back to the same but
Liat later she said we can't have sex
after I felt depressed because I knew
she didn't like me anymore and she
started liking this other guy when I was
depressed I didn't talk to her much it
lasted for three days this kid must be
young yeah it lasted for three days and
during that time she started dating the
guy brutal spelling errors to forgive my
already bad reading out loud skills here
this is almost we're about halfway
through here if you want to start
lighting this cigarette I asked her why
she went off and and dated a guy she
doesn't know she said because I was
detaching myself I want to get over I
want to get over but I'm having trouble
only time I am happy is when I listened
to stand-up comedy in your podcasts
right this year so he goes
I'm smooching your ass there I feel bad
for breaking her heart and because I
feel like she didn't love me not Jesus
Christ this guy's even make it sense I
was always there for her she had many
problems when she was alone I stuck up
for her she got I know I know I screwed
up yes and I'd note and what okay not
honestly is he alright anyways he's
basically asking how can I get over her
and move on well what do you say Dave
what is this is what I say your formulas
hoes and porn will help you in the
immediate thing but in the long-run
yeah you gotta you gotta just uh there's
whatever you got to get out there I mean
this kid he's still trying to uh trying
to like get this chick but she's already
moved on cuz yeah we all know one thing
guys got porn but women can [ __ ] any guy
they want yeah honestly I mean like if
you don't treat a woman right she will
go out and like [ __ ] your twin brother
just to show you that like you got a you
know whatever
oh that's I mean they're vicious they
are be vicious or they can be amazingly
cool so either way he you know he should
just say like you know what chalk this
one up for experience move on next
chapter in my life
yeah and use the porn and the booze
sparingly but keep it in the back pocket
and there are chicks that like porn so
maybe the next one won't have such a big
problem about it but this girl it's
called the dead-end move forward yeah I
I ever I have one of my theories is when
you break up with with someone is you
get the [ __ ] away from them good idea if
you can because women got that they're
just [ __ ] geniuses when it comes to
just knowing right well they could just
sense like wait a minute he's getting
over me and then they'll [ __ ] call
you up and just spin your [ __ ] around
and then just hang up and be I have
mission accomplished and they just do
that until they're over you and then
they just leave you in a puddle in the
corner so well my thing is you just you
just [ __ ] you break it off and that's
it exactly you're right maybe this kid
he works with this this chick where she
lives near him or something like that
but you're right he's got to clear the
decks move forward new experiences like
it's scary but you got to just get out
there and do [ __ ] but the porn
we'll help you honestly and it's such a
such a Priss about the porn thing and
you know it's amazing how she got over
here yeah well you're not gonna marry
this girl you can't watch exactly can't
watch porn what that this isn't your
wife I'm emotionally dead as an old man
here all right what else we got we got
dilemmas here Dave would you like to try
a dilemma let's write a dilemma a
dilemma let's see if we can chin till
I'm out like I've uh you know a man
stands on one foot don't know this this
is more just this is sophomoric okay
[ __ ] horse I like how bill you don't
even is this the first time you're
seeing this stuff oh yeah that's
precious
I don't read I just totally wing it all
right yeah I mean it was a really brutal
one here all right I will get this to
you Dave would you rather eat a
tablespoon of Kim Kardashian [ __ ] or
suck an entire fart directly out of
Rosie O'Donnell sucking directly on her
Abby's blue nut Wow
you know it sucks one you want to do
both it's sex one well I don't know I
would say that I would go mmm I don't
know that's a definitely coin toss if
you ask me cuz I mean if anybody shits
gonna taste good you got to think give
me she's so primped and proper you know
what I mean yeah I think she gets some
sort of a sped of cure I would think
like okay yeah yeah once a week or so if
every hole is insured by something the
boys of wonder but no she's super hot so
everybody would go with her but you know
what I'm gonna take you to the other
direction go with the Rosie whatever the
hell you say oh look at that left turn
and I'll even take it a step further
because to show you how much I really
have no self esteem
I would eat Susan Boyles box if it
granted wishes and even everybody goes
what if one of the wishes was you never
remember eating her box like I don't
even give a [ __ ]
I'm sure it's as sweet as her beautiful
voice bill oh the bill and your
hypothetical well the noises she would
make hot what the noises she would make
can you imagine I think she would wheels
ass up get there under those those
children's novel pasty thighs that's
really if she has like fairytale legs I
would think you know enemy
she is angel corts she they just queefs
angel prayers I gotta tell you I think I
would go I would go with Rosie O'Donnell
I would do that because at the end of
the day it's air it's just it just
doesn't seem as bad I'm gonna go I'm
gonna so hopped up I'm gonna get sign
yeah but you're not really experiencing
her she's just gonna [ __ ] on a plate
like basically how you get to see her do
it she doesn't like like an assistant
brings it in right you get serious she's
very busy she's she's out she's done
she's dodging the everyone who was
outraged that her sham of a marriage was
a sham of a marriage but you know I
don't understand Bill who felt who felt
they got [ __ ] in that one who do you
feel bad for the poor people at People
magazine that have a million dollars to
pay for those dumb photos I honestly
could not give a [ __ ] about any of that
[ __ ] or whatever but I'm just gonna
say this right now don't you think just
from just living in America of like you
know pumping gas and like you know using
a cash machine that like you've you've
like somehow over over your entire life
just the contact of like people of other
people touching [ __ ] that you've eaten a
[ __ ] oh absolutely yeah I think that
like if you collectively collectively
it's like probably like a nice big turd
yeah I mean you get your stomach pumped
like right when you go to heaven like
they show you like this is how much [ __ ]
you've actually you know that God gives
you that's hell like how much change
you've given to homeless people and he
has a majority you know I had somebody
in st. Louis did that you know you shake
hands afterwards you always have like
that the handstand yeah and I actually
had an audience member deny to shake my
hand he goes he goes I'm not because of
everything I was just like yeah you know
that's actually that totally I totally
understand why you wouldn't want to at
this point yeah and I always make sure
I'm gonna scratch my face it's always
with my left hand like I totally get why
you know Howie Mandel is probably the
most famous for it doesn't want to shake
hands and if people thought it was weird
but if you're really honest with
yourself and you think about the last 24
hours some of the things that you've
done to yourself
yeah and you maybe were in a hurry not
quite clean up you know
but think about it this way I've been to
the third world and like they could only
dream about it yeah and they can only
dream of like you know like soaking wet
wipes and Purell and [ __ ] like that I
mean you know they're filthy all the
time and they love it and they always a
big smile you know yeah hey what's up
don't they like [ __ ] on the side of the
road sometimes yeah they just like squat
in the one fountain that's in their
country mmm some of that yeah I've
actually seen that so have like the
people's bidet
the people's birthday is that a new show
that sounds like a new show on a new
network we look differently here they
own you know something I thought I was
gonna travel the world and find out how
bad capitalism is I actually think it's
still good I think it's good - it's a
little out of control but there's
something when everybody has everything
that's just no read there's no
motivation yeah you know what I mean you
know what's really sucks for like people
out there that listen because I've been
like starting to follow this whole like
take back you know Wall Street and all
that kind of stuff exactly even though
the message is is is very like obscure
right now they're dead on it's like a
lot of these kids especially the kids
with the heavy college debt and just
people like working at jobs like regular
- I still have like many regular jobs
okay and like the whole thing was like
okay you got a Christmas bonus you know
if the company did really well maybe get
another bonus that would be cool if you
worked for that kind of company I used
to sell shoes so I was like the more
shoes you sell like you get a bonus and
then like the next year like you know
you're like okay cool I've moved up you
know to not get a bigger salary there's
none of that people get a job they get
more work it's like oh you got to put in
another extra hours taking away from
your family and your other [ __ ] but
there's no more money so it's like it's
like that whole idea of like you know
I'm gonna work my way up in this company
or I'm gonna do this that's over it's
like it's like you should just be lucky
to have a job [ __ ] you no no I think I
think it up my life for this [ __ ] job
I want to be rewarded if I'm doing a
good job just the head guy who gets all
the bonuses and yes I asked
fundamentally what they're doing there
is right it's just a shame that they are
going to you know the couple you know
anytime there's a crowd first of all you
know there's some perverts are gonna
show up oh yeah that's like there's
South by Southwest festival when they
see it they can go dry hump up against
somebody there's always gonna be the
dude who throw something through a
[ __ ] window
yeah this is that guy like those people
it's like you go to a football game you
can sit there and have a good time but
you know there's gonna be some guy with
this man tits out somebody's gonna be
puking in the corn there's gonna be you
know when you have a crowd but
essentially what's going on there is is
good it's good for America and I think
what those kids are doing there god
bless them I like it you know it's like
I always thought this generation was
just like Xbox like sit at home you know
comment comment on everything like it
hate it you know you suck I'm talking
about my own you know I think I got that
same tension to see these like people
going out like you know trying to like
really do something so I give them
credit
I think it's phenomenally somebody some
people got together and they stopped a
bank from out they had some new chargers
which is [ __ ] hilarious cuz these
[ __ ] are the ones who screwed
everything up
who the bankers oh yeah it's like if
everybody like I don't think I don't get
how we all work every week and you
basically give them 90 percent of your
paycheck every week yeah you can you
have all the money how did you lose it
well what's the deal the bank's all I
know is this like as an old man who's
trying to support an older woman my
mother right oh I know it's like III do
the right thing I put my money in the
401k if I have some money or blah blah
blah and there's nothing in there
there's no like interest on it it's like
I might as well go out and bling it up
yeah I mean maybe these rappers are
right go out and just buy you know a
clock and a car you don't need in a
helicopter at least you have something
they're like looking at your bank
statement zero zero point one whatever
like you're lucky if it like makes like
five bucks or sorry and the dumbest
thing I ever did was invest in some
paper out you can't get it back they'll
give it back to you but with the
penalties and the fees and then those
[ __ ] like every five years they
just yanked a rug out from underneath it
you know every once in a while they will
arrest like some lady who makes a bundt
cake and they'll send her to jail and
say that she did something [ __ ] up but
the real heavyweights down there come on
I don't even I don't even understand
like this whole euro thing with the
unless these bail out Greece
everyone's gonna fall like Spain and in
Portugal like there's like the these
countries it seems like the cooler the
country is the more at risk they are of
their economy falling apart like yeah
Germany very straight and you know
whatever rigid you know everyone they're
like the strongest economy and then like
Norway and Sweden whatever but once you
get into like the places where you can
get a tan you know like Portugal's name
you know the fun places and you know
what somebody talk about comedy over
there they said that you don't want to
go south of Berlin once you go south of
Berlin immediately they just want to see
a titty pop out and somebody slip on a
banana peels very Benny Hill oh really
south of that so you know if you want to
pontificate you got to go to like the
Netherlands oh you got to stay up that
way I don't know how you guys do it I
know Stanhope who I think is the best
comic I've ever seen because he's the
most filthiest dirtiest never holds back
he's he's our Jeremiah Johnson if you
know movies he's our the last renegade
but he he really is living the life that
guy he really is is amazing and you
doesn't ladders on but what he like
lives in like the Sahara Desert now he
lives in in Arizona I didn't want to say
now he lives in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere yeah he's getting ready for the
apocalypse like Sarah Connor he's doing
that by the way he's you'll be hearing
that a lot on Bill's episode of Dave's
all porn he's actually he's doing
everything Sarah Connor did except the
pull ups that had that whole part with
the working so hot oh my god that was
like that was the beginning of women cop
show you remember it's like you know
this sassy broads gonna change this
whole department that's right and every
every show is ballplayer be your partner
yeah it's like Fred dryer what was that
show member that chick with the hair all
teased up I don't know but I'd love to
be one of those like you know peg do you
think this is this is this is not
procedure you know like just one of the
guys who fuels her her like her animes
amazing in season three cuz around us
that around like story ideas you guys
actually have like a scene where you get
to bang her in her way her power suit on
there in her [ __ ] desk that's like I
guess like Ryan Reynolds guest stars is
the lawyer you know like they have to
get like a really good-looking do
because it's all for women and women's
fantasy I know all right well we're
coming down towards the end of your
let's go we finish yeah yeah let's do
the
even want more there Dave okay one more
time for some reason I love I keep from
saying this [ __ ] like it's a live radio
show and people are just tuning in but I
I'm old school
maybe maybe somebody's walking by
somebody's cubicle
I have Dave Attell here he's he's
promoting his new [ __ ] show on Showtime
Dave's old porn I'm very happy with it
it's very good oh yeah I I saw some
clips of it as [ __ ] hilarious
I hate all my stuff but I'm like the
comics is super funny the porn people
are great so I'm very cool with it
that's awesome so uh this Thursday 11:30
on Showtime 11:30 p.m. you can see yours
truly hanging with dave and nina hartley
if you want to go to his website and
stable dave's old porn calm that's
that's every all the infos all that
dave's all porn doctor hold dave's old
porn calm all right you want do a couple
more dilemmas let's get [ __ ] silly
here and then we'll get out of it right
sorry sorry alright Jackie Jackie O or
Marilyn Monroe you know what I never
really found either one of them um that
hot but I'd have to say I guess Marilyn
Monroe would be the cooler the cooler
one you know she had a major [ __ ]
bunt yeah she was Jews never see no know
how out of shape you could be and still
be hot back in the day that's true but
she was definitely like I guess you know
the first party girl that like we all
know there's other ones like Jayne
Mansfield and all the rest the ones at a
dance field then they would have the
picture like the guys in World War two
would be like that's what I'm fighting
for Bo I think Jane's Jane Jane
Mansfield is the Kurt Cobain and and
Marilyn Monroe is Eddie Vetter you
couldn't even think of women just saying
because she I think Jane Mansfield was
the was the real [ __ ] deal I agree
with didn't she yet she got her face
peeled off and everything there's a lot
of like lines there it was a horrible
ending yeah that really was that there's
actually a word for that something that
happened no there's something that
happened to her it wasn't decapitated
she had something else that what though
it's on a wiki PDP I understand and
something that they always what is it
it's what it means basically you get
scalped oh there's a medical ID well you
got to say she was in a car
Siddhant I'm sorry yes she was in a car
accident but what the weightlifter guy
was her husband right but he lived
yeah the 18-wheeler I think he ducked
and she didn't oh and they went you know
it's basically their favorite section is
when they opened you up well which one
would you take there of Maryland that's
what I want to do I just want to bang
some chick that I don't give a [ __ ] for
a couple of months B Maryland Jackie if
I want to get married I want to settle
down and deal with her and her long
[ __ ] gloves and she seems yeah can
you look up Jane Mansfield and find out
what the medical term is for being
scalped if you don't mind
Patrick Melton everybody host of the one
of the original pods out there nobody
likes onions anyway so let's let's do
another dilemma here so patrick has his
own podcast besides your podcast no no
this is his studio he's allowing me to
be here that's why the quality of this
it's really professional is is so
[ __ ] amazing all right Dave would you
would you rather never have sex again or
be able to have sex but you can only
Taco Bell breakfast lunch and dinner for
the rest of your life that's called
comedy in the 80s yeah that one was
[Laughter]
scalping like tickets or helping yeah
she died she dies she went to like the
top of her head like what do you owe me
to look up I'm just just going a
Wikipedia page hmm Jane Jane Jane
Mansfield
Wow that's your 24 makes it look so much
more exciting when they have the guy now
look up this they get it in like five
seconds yeah and you know what happens
everybody gathers around the computer
yeah and nobody could see it nobody can
see it except for the hero
they got whatever was just way off girl
yeah
typing typing ah that was a good one
though but I would say they anything we
talk about I like Taco Bell but I'm old
now so talk about was like eating candy
like you can only do it occasionally but
I used to live on talk about growing up
on Long Island we get wasted we'd
[ __ ] hit the hit the Taco Bell and
seven layer burrito everything we just
like like give us everything because we
know eventually we're gonna eat it
you know it's just like tons of stuff
you know I love about them is there
their attempt to keep coming up with new
dishes with those same four ingredients
you know just bluing
chips together with [ __ ] with the
cheese and then the hamburger meat it's
always the hamburger meat some sort of
taco and then of just a bunch of [ __ ]
cheese I'll and they just change the
shape of it I actually I would say I
would just not have sex again and
because I figure if I eat enough if I
eat Taco Bell three times a day I'm
gonna [ __ ] die and my or my dick just
isn't gonna work with all that grease in
there anyways so I might as well eat
healthy you know I'll take yoga class
and try to teach myself how to come
without touching myself and the down dog
position I thought that it says her
destiny but says she was killed by a
crushed skull with an avulsion of
cranium and brain of halogen lookup
avulsion maybe that's what it was but
back to the Taco Bell thing I think
that's one of that new new dishes and
avulsion is an injury in which the body
structure is forcibly detached it's most
commonly refers to a surface trauma
where all the layers of the skin have
been torn away exposing the underlying
structures subcutaneous tissue muscle
tendons it's similar to an abrasion but
much more severe as body parts such as
an eyelid or an ear can be partially or
fully detached from the body
oh that's why she got a face peel done
from the Latin word to tear off yeah
dude you know those [ __ ] drug cartels
down in Mexico they tortured this guy to
death they [ __ ] peeled his face back
no way really yeah and I was just
thinking of all the sick jokes because
when you pull it back it just looks like
the guys doing the cheesiest smile ever
oh I know cuz it's just you know it's
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what was
it was the movie you know what the
pinhead guy you know pinhead but was it
called pinhead
no but what was the name of the movie
though Hellraiser Hellraiser yeah you
know rip the skin off boy I love that
guy I love that but a bell volume what I
want to say was uh that Mexican stuff is
it crazy whatever's going on down there
that's [ __ ] crazy and they got a new
show while Juarez Mexico
I haven't watched it yet but I bet you
that's like that is definitely the town
what we should do a special oh yeah can
you imagine ever like Mako City it's
like do we get paid here yeah here's
your pay you get to leave a line get out
it's like okay okay we're backing across
the bridge
relax everything's good relax how
hardcore would you go though I know I
know that you have performed for troops
on bases oh yeah in Afghanistan and all
these hardcore places but what's the
most hardcore parasail you you know what
I'm talking about
no you left the country mm-hmm cuz
there's something like a there's a major
[ __ ] fear I have when I when you
leave the country as much as you having
a good time it's a friendly [ __ ]
place it says that panic I'm gonna lose
my wallet and I'm gonna have to run to
the Embassy is like in the background
like people chasing me and [ __ ] so I was
wondering Jason Bourne the most I'm just
saying I'm not saying it's a rational
[ __ ] it that's hilarious is what what
fantasy are you in well you've got a
gift to the embassy I'll tell you why
did you ever watch arrested abroad and
it locked up abroad locked up abroad or
or that that chick who's she's she's put
away forever because she doing something
you know washed up for losing your
wallet tell this is what it is captain
cynical lot of an iron series saying
bill yeah that girl who went to Bali she
said she packed a boogie board when it
[ __ ] lands it's packed with weed and
if you get a life sentence like you get
the [ __ ] death penalty they didn't
give her the death penalty they just
stuck her in jail for life they made
this whole documentary on it you think
in the end she's gonna get I don't know
no ruin it's [ __ ] horrific now maybe
she was trying to deal
I'm not saying but she didn't look up
the laws she didn't know what the [ __ ]
was going on and that was it yeah but
you're talking about people who are
doing something wrong
most likely getting caught I did say it
was a rat littering and came in
Singapore remember that's a Kea card
like I mean I've been all these
countries I don't look up their laws I
just go I'm not gonna be a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah you know the laws of the land but
whatever you do meaning somebody and
they they leave a [ __ ] uh one of
those little things you smoke out of not
a bong the little pipes are Pike one air
a one-hitter mmm you got that and all of
a sudden that means you got to get
[ __ ] your foot stepped on by an
elephant right and you weren't aware
that I met the love of your life in
Saudi Arabia on that oil business trip I
always like it's like I grew up in Saudi
Arabia
it's like wad it's again like
if you could get booze you were the man
and so it's like you know like that's
real hardcore like we're in the u.s.
would be like and but like if you feel
like a bottle of Kahlua it's like whoa
watch out all something like secret
police or [ __ ] getting this kid
whatever that Joe locked up abroad very
cool you're absolutely well we about an
hour
I don't I went in our we're gonna wrap
it up this podcast it's good see once
again I can't wait for the new special
whenever you're gonna do that because
your stuff rocks out always I love it
I'm chasing guys like you Dave's old
porn is a new show Thursday's 11:30 on
Showtime it's a big hit dude I'm really
happy for you man I'm happy bill goes
check over the moon for you man that's
it that's the Monday morning podcast
hope you guys had a good time thank you
guys don't take any [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourselves we'll talk to you next week
you